a Solo dos kilómetros de la línea del
frente en bulevar estos médicos
militares están en contacto permanente
con los soldados de las trincheras los
heridos siguen llegando muchos de ellos
mueren tras perder demasiada sangre este
combatiente transportado en ambulancia
pudo ser atendido a tiempo bulear Ciudad
minera del este de Ucrania al sur de
bakmuth es uno de los últimos objetivos
de las fuerzas rusas que afirman estar
ganando terreno
al sur de cerca de las unidades del
frente Oriental han continuado sus
exitosas operaciones ofensivas
ganaron posiciones e infligieron una
derrota a los ucranianos en bulevard en
la República Popular de doniasca
pero los ucranianos afirman que están
haciendo retroceder a las fuerzas rusas
y defendiendo sus posiciones en la
región más al norte en bakmuth meses de
combates han causado numerosas bajas en
ambos bandos este soldado de 28 años es
una de las víctimas de esta guerra
murió cerca de Back mood lo alcanzó la
explosión de una mina
debemos trabajar sin descanso para
liberar nuestra tierra de los intrusos
que no invitamos a entrar en nuestras
Casas
sin embargo el presidente ucraniano voló
de mí ha reconocido que la situación en
torno a bacmut y vulevar es delicada y
podría deteriorarse aún más los rusos
multiplican los puntos de ataque Y
esperan una victoria tras numerosos
reveses sobre el terreno